What's up guys welcome back to the king of random I'm Nate, thanks for joining us today
Recently we had a video where we showed you how to make your very own foam balloon generator. Well today
We've got some experiments that are going to take that to the next level first
I want to point out that I've changed my formula a little bit before I was using bubble soap with a ratio of about one
Part bubble soap to seven parts water and while that still works great
I think I've had slightly better results by using a foaming hand soap
I use one part foaming hand soap to two parts water
So it's not quite as
Concentrated of a base to start with but I think it makes a slightly better phone since that's what this type of soap was designed
For the experiment that so many of you wanted us to try was using food coloring to see if we could make our foam come
Up as colored bubbles instead of white blue is usually the most concentrated food coloring color
So I'm going to add plenty of that to our liquid and then blow some bubbles in and see what happens to our foam
Because I want to give these bubbles the best chance of picking up the blue color, I'm using a lot of dye
Probably only would have taken about one drop to turn all of this water blue
Nice dark blue
diluted soap all right now
I'm just gonna use my mouth and blow some air in to see if we get any sort of color in these bubbles
There you go, you can see that there really isn't almost any blue tint
There's maybe it looks like a little bit down at the bottom
But I think you're just seeing through the bubbles to the blue liquid below the actual foam as it comes off really
Has no color whatsoever. It's still the same shade of white that it was before so let's talk about what's happening
And why we aren't getting any color in the bubbles themselves when the bubbles are forming
They're an extremely thin film surrounding. Whatever gas. It was that filled them up
It's so thin that it really isn't able to hold any color of its own
So the soap that's forming these bubbles actually contains the blue dye in it
But it's spread out so much that it can't really add any color to it the reason these look white is they're actually clear
Reflecting the light around and since all the light we have shining in the studio and outside is white light the bubbles appear
white
The only way to really change the color would be to either use a colored smoke to fill them
Or if you've shown a different color like on to the bubbles so unfortunately because bubbles are so thin
It looks like using food coloring to dye. The bubbles doesn't work out too. Well however. I do have a few other things
I don't want to try the first of which is using hydrogen to fill these bubbles instead of helium. Let's take this outside
So here we have our giant tank of hydrogen our pressure regulator
Which is apparently absolutely essential to getting hydrogen safely out of a tank so we have that it's got two different valves to control
Actually, it's got three valves one here
And then two on the regulator just to control very carefully the speed and pressure at which our hydrogen is leaving the tank
I've got our bubble soap already
I'm still using the blue stuff because why waste bubble soap, but as we've learned unfortunately that will not give us blue bubbles
Let's see if the hydrogen has any more lift to it than the helium did
open this valve and
Then as I slowly turn this one it will let a little bit of hydrogen through at a time and that
Will immediately start bubbling up down in our pan?
A little bit windy out here today, so our bubbles are already straining to get free get it free see what happens
Boom flying up into the air
Obliterate chop into thousand pieces by the tree branches
Whoo balloon attacked our cameraman I
Think we've shown that hydrogen works pretty well probably lifts even better than helium now
I want to try cutting a stencil shape out of foam core to see if we can control the shape of the foam balloons coming
out of our generator
Well I think to start out we'll just try a triangle
It's not the most perfect triangle I've ever seen but I think it'll work
Now I do want this to sit flush
So I'm gonna add a little bit of a notch
Where the hose comes out just so I'm not squishing that I'll seal it all up with tape so it's on there pretty well
It looks like it should work all right
All right looks like our board is pretty well attached
So let's see if we can get some triangle-shaped bubbles come out of our foam generator
Hmm
Well it's not working wonderfully our stencil isn't really doing much to control the shape of the bubbles so I have an idea that I
want to try to see if we can get the bubbles to travel in a more uniform direction part of the problem is that they're
Coming from all sides, and they're really getting squished through sort of a bottleneck
There's also the fact that our bubbles are a little larger than I'd like them to be which makes it so it's hard to get
Any sort of resolution or definition in our stencil as the bubbles are coming out through it?
So I've put our whole bubble generator down at the bottom of a bucket
And I want to see if that makes a difference in how it rises up out
I think we might be able to have a more smooth uniform
Transition with the bubbles rising out this way well test it alright
Let's see how this works out
So far so good
Making bubbles they float large part of what we're going for right there
Yeah, we're getting nice thin layers of bubbles now, that's a step in a good direction
Now these bubbles are still a little larger as in each individual
Bubble is a larger size than I would ideally like
But there's also the fact that as the bubbles fill up the whole bucket the excess bubble fluid
That's around them has more of a chance to drain off so we have what's actually a little bit dryer of bubbles
And I'm hoping that that will also work better with our stencils
Let's give this another shot letting it grow a little too high at first just to let it even out
Hey look that looks like a triangle
It's not a great triangle, but its triangle
Ha shapes, I'm just let this one go for a little bit. We're getting a nice prism shape
All right that worked out pretty well now
I'm gonna try a slightly more complicated shape and see if we can get that to work
We've got a king for a king of random. We're gonna see if we can make some bubble
hydrogen foam caves
float through the air
Here we go here we go
That we're facing the camera better, you'd be able to see how a case shaped it was here's another one
That worked okay, it wasn't perfect, but it was a whole lot better than nothing we got some good shapes out of it
Let's move on in the next experiment, which is to see how big we can make this work?
I've taken this three-foot plastic bright pink kitty pool
Run clear hose and Aspire all the way through it poke holes in the hose all the way around we're gonna pour a whole bunch
Of our fluid into here run hydrogen down through the hose and see if we can make some giant foam balloons for
Bubble fluid we already have in
We're gonna need a whole lot more than that
All right, I think at this point all of our hose is completely submerged
That's what we want for some good. Even bubbles. Let's add some gas and see how this works. Well. You can definitely see it
forming a
Lot of bubbles
It's all sort of pushing to one side of the tub as the wind blows on it, Oh
Big one there it goes
And there goes an even bigger one from the wind oh
Boy that's just spinning around it got caught in some little sideways tornado or something
That's funny. It looks like a car wash exploded
There are no wind I think this would work. I think we'd have like a column of this that I could like jump roars
I've been
Yep there you go that is working pretty well, I think it would work better
If it weren't quite so windy out here
but I do think we're getting bubbles about as large as we could possibly get there gets to a point where there's just like the
Maximum amount of lift that bubbles can hold on to they don't have a whole lot of cohesion to themselves however
There is of course one more thing I do want to try we are using hydrogen gas to fill these balloons
And hydrogen is flammable, so I've got myself a little makeshift torch here that I've been using just as a stick
But now I'm gonna add some fuel light this up and when a bubble goes off
I'm gonna try and poke it and ignite it here goes
Haha break free break free you can do it
This is the greatest game ever oh don't worry
Should be a big one
Still good whoo five seconds awesome
Haha
Yeah, just wait. It's just hovered right above it, and I don't want to like the pool on fire
So I had to wait for it to move somewhere. Oh a big one here we go
Got it
Like fending off an attack cover yet really got back bubbles back
Hot bubble soap wave them
This is the greatest game ever played it was like Harry Potter King around stuff, Alakazam incendio
Laughs I didn't even float
Oh, it's coming right at my face
Oh
That was safe that wasn't nearly as dramatic as I thought it me neither probably for the best yeah
Huh that does look really cool actually
I'm sure this is not at all safe
It just kind of circles and snakes around chasing itself
There you have it lining a three foot kiddie pool with our tube with holes poked in it filling that with bubble soap and
Setting that off with hydrogen makes some great foam balloons and best of all it's flammable so you can have a really fun time pretending
You're a wizard like poking at balloons, and they just explode. It's great fun
This is seriously very entertaining even if you aren't lighting them off if you just do it with helium
It's way fun making these balloons and just chasing them and hitting it and swatting them stuff like that
It's easy to do at home the little version. It's cheap. It's quick. You can definitely make your own foam balloons
I highly recommend it
Thank you guys for your suggestions of things you wanted to see us try if you've got any other ideas
Please let us know down in the comments
Thanks for joining us for this project today, and we look forward to the next one talk to you then
Huh, oh no oh it's too high now, I can't get that I want lightning to strike it haven't just blow up
You know that Santa Claus trick?
Haha that was a good one
You